my apologies Your Grace Your Grace Your
Grace your grace for the princess's
talents you're great that was most
Charice of all of you young Grace the
Royal Huntsman has sent to report your
Grace has been a sighting I don't wish
to cause you further distress your grace
to whom
Your Grace the lady Lena is Young Your
Grace I have no such intent Your Grace
that's hardly how I viewed it your grace
the Stag is the king of the king's wood
Your Grace a Regal potent for Prince
aegon's name day Your Grace I'm sorry
your grace his grace would never lower
himself to entertain such a mum as fast
for an era excuse me your grace
I apologize for the early Army on Grace
Lord Callis has overreached your grace
Your Grace I've called a small Council
to an emergency session shall we discuss
the heirs tournament Your Grace you're
great the Huntsman has the trail new
Grace what must I say
right I only wish that were true Your
Grace will you honor me you're great
Your Grace it is the morning your grace
your grace